[Music]
for many years I was focused on health
policy and I actually worked with the
Clinton administration to try to pass
health reform and when a colleague of
mine came and said you know what's the
next important thing you want to work on
what are the big problems I said you
know clearly care coordination is the
big problem and so I took it on and
started doing work around it and you
know like everybody else I came across
my own you know horror story really my
father got ill he spent more time than
we would have liked in the medical care
system going from Doctor to doctor going
from hospital to hospital my siblings
and I did our very best to keep a
notebook with all the notes and we would
transmit the information as best we
could from Doctor to doctor and you know
ultimately I say that my father passed
away because of a care coordination
failure so the the problem that I care a
lot about and have focused a great deal
of my research on recently has been care
coordination I call it integrated care
the reason I call it integrated care is
because I feel like it goes beyond just
mere coordination I really feel like
integration is something more holistic
because it accounts for all of the
customization that's required to care
for a particular patient so it is the
communication and it is the coordination
but it's also it's done on behalf of
each individual patient according to the
patient's needs
traditionally the system has grown up in
silo so doctors have trained alone
nurses have chained separately they're
trained to optimize what it is they do
not so much to communicate with each
other and that's it's the between the
cracks where the problems occur so
information doesn't transmit when
information doesn't transmit you know if
a patient's been in a hospital and then
they go home if that information about
the hospitalization doesn't get back to
the primary care provider that patient
is at risk for not having a follow-up
appointment is much more likely to get
readmitted back to the hospital if a
primary care physician refers a patient
out for a screening exam but doesn't get
the information about the result of that
exam back that patient is at risk for
not having the appropriate follow-up
we have a traditional payment system in
the US where predominantly providers are
still paid on a fee-for-service basis
that means if they perform a service
they get a fee for that service that
encourages providers to provide more
services it does not encourage providers
to spend time coordinating care on
behalf of their patients and so there
are efforts to reform the payment
systems in ways that align the
incentives with the kinds of initiatives
that I've been talking about so rather
than a strict fee-for-service there are
experiments around for example
accountable care organizations and some
accountable care organizations assume
risk for either physician services or
for all services and you have more of an
incentive to try and create the kinds of
processes and programs that I've been
describing that allow the providers to
attend to the coordination needs of
those patients
for decades the VA has been a leader in
terms of quality and efficiency of the
care that they deliver on behalf of the
veterans and the reason that they have
been so far ahead of the rest of the
system in the u.s. is because it's an
integrated delivery system it's kind of
one of the very few we have examples of
in the United States the primary doctors
and the specialists and the hospitals
they're all part of the same system and
they have for decades shared an
electronic medical record system which
means that as a primary care doctor I
could see what the specialist has done
on behalf of my patient and I can follow
up in a way that in the private health
care system we very often don't have the
ability to do so for those reasons they
have had great advantages to be able to
deliver high quality and more integrated
care and they have had their share of
visionary leaders who've really
prioritized quality and and coordination
and patient centeredness and when you
have that along with caring for your
patient you know the combination of
those things are pretty powerful
everybody really wants to do their best
they're instituting a new program called
their care coordination and integrated
case management program they're creating
hierarchical levels of interventions so
for their very most complex patients
they have one set of processes so they
are actually assigning a care
coordinator to work with that patient
and the family to go with that patient
to their different visits and to make
sure that the information flows back to
their primary care doctor and for the
next swath of patients still complex but
a little bit less so they have another
level of intervention and then for a
level down from there a third level of
intervention so they're trying to assign
the resources according to the needs of
the patients
we've gone into practice sites to try to
understand what they're doing what tools
they're using to try to tease out what
what's a better practice then then not a
better practice and interestingly when
we did this initially over 150 practice
sites we couldn't discern anything that
was differentiating them the things that
we expected would be differentiating
whether they had a shared electronic
medical record system whether they were
multidisciplinary whether they were
sophisticated in terms of their IT or
sophisticated in terms of their care
management processes none of those
things systematically related to
improving integration for their patients
and so we went to organizations that the
patient's suggested were high performing
versus low performing to try to tease
out some of the differences and what we
finally discerned kind of at its essence
was that organizations could take
whatever resources they had available
whether it be a sophisticated electronic
medical record system or whether it was
a kind of individual resource like a
care management person within the
organization so long as they took those
resources and really focus their
attention on on the goal which was to
integrate care for the patients there
were lots of different paths to getting
there
if somebody says I want to start where
should I start I always tell them to
measure first to find out where their
unique strengths are and where their
unique challenges are and once they have
that they can really create for
themselves a road map that I think makes
sense because every organization is
going to be a little bit different that
way
what we're looking at is is trying to
get people to make incremental
improvement there's a tremendous amount
of focus on this country in the next
great you know drug or the next great
device and instead my research focus is
on kind of the next great improvement in
ways that we can transmit information
and coordinate care because if we don't
do that then the you know the the drug
is you know not going to produce the
benefit that we need it to produce if we
have a procedure you know because it's a
great new procedure that we're able to
do with some sort of automated robotic
way of doing it you know that's
tremendous but if there is an
appropriate follow-up for that patient
they're not going to benefit from having
that procedure and they can end up
either worse off or back into the
hospital and so in order to make them
work well we need cultures within
organizations and people with any
organizations that prioritize the their
combination so it's going to be very
incremental but if we could actually
move the ball down the field we'd be
saving you know life after life after
life it would be a game-changer
[Music]
you